[Music]  ah  [Music]  oh no crashing eddie went back to the  lost world and i thought i made bad  choices  hello boys but wild at your service our  hero  what brings you two to my world we want  to live a life of adventure like you  it's a bad time for a tropical vacation  everyone we face a grave threat can you  repeat that i had a marshmallow in my  ear  ah crashing eddie you've been gone a  while  shouldn't we just be looking for bones  at this point thanks sid  this is our chance to prove ourselves  boys what you lack in intelligence  destiny  [Applause]  oh destiny hurts  you make up for him bumbling ineptitude  if we don't find them i'm gonna kill  them  [Applause]  [Music]  you